Rachel's our first one up in Vancouver
British Columbia so Rachel what is your
net worth our net worth is right around
2.7 2.8 okay cool and break that down
for me how's that invested we've got
some million dollars in investments
about half of that is in retirement half
of that it's just regular brokerage
accounts and then we've got about
somewhere between 1.7 1.8 in equity in
real estate okay very good excellent how
old are you 35 oh wow young millionaires
well done good job so how much of this
did you inherit we inherited about three
hundred eighty-six thousand a year and a
half ago from my grandfather when he
passed away so you were already
multimillionaires before yeah so you did
not become a millionaire because of
inherited money
oh cool all right very cool and Rachel
do you remember your worst income year
and your best income yet my worst was
when I started working I was making
$27,000 a year out of school our best
income year between my husband and I was
about two years ago and that was 220,000
we're right now we're down to 160 and
that's because we both become
self-employed we start their own
companies or I'm working I'm doing my
family's company and buying in and then
my husband has started his own
engineering firm so taking a bit of a
pay cut there but with the long-term
view to the grower incomes even higher
hmm okay and so your husband is an
engineer what is your profession I'm a
mechanical contractor so we do plumbing
and heating for commercial buildings
gotcha and did you all attend college we
did my husband has is four years civil
engineering degree and I did a two-year
civil instructional engineering diploma
and then went on to get my construction
management degree and an MBA but those I
did part-time like a night and worked
throughout very good do you recall your
GPA
I was probably 3.8 okay my husband's
probably 3.3 3.4 oh yes and how much of
this wealth do you have because you
borrowed money to create wealth
we only borrowed for mortgages so when
we bought our first place we had a
mortgage on that and then we that was a
condo and then we moved up to a house
about four years ago and we had to
borrow again because we didn't have
enough equity when we sold the condo to
pay for the full house but that's that's
been it not you okay cool so is it
possible for somewhere to start
I mean you're only 35 is it possible for
somebody that's listening is 20 to 27
years old that they could be worth a
couple million dollars by the time
they're 40 yes I think the biggest thing
is what you guys talk about a lot is
just being intentional like we've made a
good income but especially ever since
learning about your every dollar app and
downloading that a couple years ago
that's just made us even more focus and
I feel its accelerated things because we
see exactly where our money is going
it's so easy to go out to dinner a few
nights a week her to go for coffee or
lunch every day
and you just have to set your priorities
and where you want to go with your money
and you just have to be intentional or
they ignore what everybody else is
saying or doing yeah how much TV do you
guys watch we don't have cable we don't
have cable
you know so I'm a books a year to y'all
read I've actually started tracking that
and this year so far ever at 25
nonfiction Wow what's the best nan
Ramsey non-fiction book you've read this
year a really good one that recently
finished was called the rational
optimist by Matt Ridley it was very good
it was about sort of the ability of
human beings to overcome challenges as a
whole and so it was they want to read
given the current for a negative
atmosphere that's out there yeah no
doubt no doubt you know it's amazing
that there's that I'm gonna have to read
that I like the thesis of it already
that's true right the rational optimist
it fits almost with the whole discussion
we're having this hour so very very cool
so what advice would you give to the 25
year old you steady pay attention be
intentional what else and just be
independent like get off Facebook get
off Instagram like that's not real life
and just the sort of Rachel's message
about love your life not theirs and do
what you want to do and forget about all
the noise you don't need the hair
extensions you don't need the fancy
vacation if you don't want it like just
set your goals and follow what's true to
you yeah very cool
very well done Rachel congratulations
we're excited for you guys you got a
beautiful future ahead of you and you've
done a wonderful job to get where you
are very well done